vous vous excusez le jeu se trouve sur
la gare you mais attention ce retour sur
l'édition hardcore dagar you vous allez
voir ça change c'est parti on est sûr à
savoir hardcore ça veut dire que les
masses contre ou faux entre 1 et 50
points on va dire voilà il ya des masses
totalement et non regardez comment
grosse évident [ __ ] c'est jouissif
bordel c'est vrai un fois que je joue je
jouis déjà et on se déplace deux fois
plus vite que dans la version originale
de la gare y aurait un léger absurde est
déjà énorme
hollywood se trouvait c'est le rêve de
tout joueur d'à guerriau ce qui se passe
actuellement ça va très vite
gueriot adore édition assas et les virus
en fait on moi j'ai un truc qui paye qui
représente une masse de sang il nous
divisent en mille morceaux à sa pizza
pâtes harpe attachement ballesta cnil
veut nous attirer c'est un piège un pin
up là haut placées moi qui t'ai mis dans
la gare on mange des masses de plus sa
voix soul wash away [ __ ] par contre le
premier les verts quoi en rien les jeux
ce poney d'un coup je me fais manger on
blague plus on va s'appeler à je veux
vivre [ __ ] c'est pas savoir de fond
d'elle ça moi je vous le dire je vais
aller la bonne vague coovadia fait son
coin là haut on black plus haut on est
venu pour vaincre widadi dadida des
détails à j'adorais attention est bien
il est grand un peu molle et la société
vient de manger
attention vous êtes je me suis fait
chier dessus ça marche et je lui ai
échappé au maire c'est tiens tiens
certes rtth te rend justement tous n'en
vient pas des mecs à plus tard y'a de la
masse par ici ça tient son propre nom il
y avait un virus bien là bien là bien là
bien là tu fais quoi tu fais quoi tu
fais quoi et batum holla holla holla
holla holla holla oui c'est moche
aulas oui mais cuisant et je me suis
enflammé aaa
il m'a eu à [ __ ] les mecs il a
vraiment humiliée alors à temps mais
arrêter sa suzuki cerveau et le royaume
du sprint il
bonjour ce sont des masses à plus haut
il veut manger cet [ __ ]
c'est pas grave parce qu'on voit au pays
des mas d'azil mange mon petit peu aucun
problème à ces pays des merveilles ma
démarche je me ferai jamais attends toi
tu as voulu manger quand je tiens qu'un
enfant sébastien bâtard a par contre
subi les goûts quelle erreur médicale et
rolala alors là l'humiliation on l'a
enterré à la pioche pour ja rule a mis
les coups de hache dans le crâne
non car toi toi c'est même à ce bâtard
olaru il va chauffer l'huile à plat non
si j'avais au au mercy mec
merci tiens je te rends on a fait une
alliance avec un russe hausse
exceptionnelle ce qui se passe moi
j'aime bien quand j'ai jeté [ __ ] les
stocks tchèque
tiens mon grand tient au maire n'a pas
pu manger l'autre c'était trop beau ce
qui s'est passé ce thème l'histoire
d'amour je te bases il s'appelle we
attend le tubesque perso toi mais on va
te défoncer vient la ola qui sait qui de
base maintenant mec d'action du siècle
[Musique]
vous voulez voir monsters qu'il m'a
match 5 et 6 mai café voilà bah vous
l'avez vu voilà c'est juste pas moi qui
les fais trois mandats foire d'art j'ai
vu j'ai dû me battre avec je te baise
tiens je te rauparaha il m'a baisé à au
moins bon mais tellement l'air
mettez-moi en l'air mais tellement on aa
non au nom voilà voilà [ __ ] mais qui
marche et moi je suis derrière je pense
et je me faisais rien à penser que va
mourir moi le moi je parie que non un
truc un peu le coup de génie
je me suis enflammé au nom battu quoi je
vais tout donner à lui tient bien
hongrois viens viens viens c'est pour
toi mon grand c'est manger l'autre
comptant dans les quinze minutes
suivantes squeeze donald meilleur de lui
même
mais on sait qu'il est nul à chier at il
réussi à faire quelques furious bonjour
san enregistrait plus le gameplay parce
qu'il avait plus de place son disque dur
vous pouvez voir qu'on est énorme et
qu'on a fait une alliance avec ce mec
français qui est vraiment au top du top
et bertrand de les français là dans les
français on est septième on blague plus
belge taminco temps tient france et des
français je suis à présent sur patins
à la faux compris mon gars y compris à
toi tu es vraiment une merde toi on va
crever rey à s'en péter le qi bao est ce
qu'on peut dire que c'est la fin oui
voilà on a perdu dix mille masse est ce
qu'on pleure bas bien sûr qu'on pleure
avant elle nourrit il avait pour lui
c'est vrai au pourquoi mais c'est
incroyable ce qui se passe sous nos yeux
ébahis
c'est un croix epic fail ses 3es milano
d'où il peut pas de manger pour le mans
aidez moi
i'm gonna shine c'est la fin c'est la
fin c'est la fin d'un règne c'est la fin
d'un vive la france
abonnez vous
[Musique]